when we're in a relationship one of the
haunting thoughts that can make us
especially snappy and bitter is the idea
that if only we were single we would be
a lot happier we can be so conscious of
the troubles of our own lives that we're
naturally drawn to look back and
remember the nicer aspects of solitude
we remember being able to get up
whenever we wanted we recall not having
to fret about where we threw things we
remember how inoffensive our own bad
habits were when we were the only ones
to witness them we recall not having to
justify our meal choices
however eccentric we could go out
somewhere and never tell anyone we could
when we felt like it work through till
2:00 a.m. without being accused of being
obsessive or cold though we were
sometimes sad we could at least always
hope for a better future
it was also fulfilling in comparison
with the life we lead now but memory is
a hugely unreliable and therefore
reckless instrument which isn't a small
point for our powers of recall have a
huge impact on how we assess our lives
in the present we are editors of genius
who know just enough about how to
romanticize our single days in order to
poison of conjugal ones some of our
ingratitude might be eroded if long
before we met anyone a talented
filmmaker were charged with making a
close observational documentary about
our lives as single people they'd
capture our face at 5:30 p.m. on a
winter Sunday afternoon as the Sun was
setting and we knew we'd be alone till
we reach the office on Monday morning
they'd observe us looking across the
room at someone at a party longing for
their kindly face but lacking any
courage to go up and address them they'd
capture us spending a lot of time at our
parents house growing increasingly
tetchy in their company they show us
struggling to know what to do when the
fridge stopped working or we felt a
terrible pain in the middle of the night
we would ideally be required to view
this documentary at regular intervals
especially after bruising fights with
our partners it would provide crucial
evidence which our own memories are so
good at strategically amid
of how less-than-ideal the single state
can be we would realize that though we
are sad now we were also very sad then
we would accept with good grace and a
touch of dark humor that life simply
gives us few opportunities to be content
you